kayla
is in salem oregon hi kayla welcome to
the dave ramsey show
hello better than i deserve how can
anthony not help
um in a little bit of a predicament
so about three years ago i bought a
duplex with my mom um the whole goal
was to fix it up um keep it for a few
years live there obviously and then turn
around
and sell it um initially
it was we went into it to split it at 50
cents and then
work away um you know with some cash to
go out on our own and start our lives
and so on and so forth um and we
recently just
sold it and now
it has kind of blown up um a little bit
she has gone back on the whole 50
thing claims that that was never a deal
um
and we profited about 115 000 and now
she's telling me that i'm only going to
get
15 or 20 of that
and fifteen thousand dollars that we
made ourselves how is she in control of
this is it in her name
no sir we went into it um
i guess you know together both of our
names are on the wall
then she doesn't get to decide yeah
yeah that's kind of it's it's been a
difficult situation so why we initially
went into it was because she went
through with divorce
um and so she couldn't afford to buy a
house by herself that's not anything to
do with this
yeah yeah i guess yeah
so is your name on the deed is your name
on the deed
yes are there any written documentations
as to this partnership that you entered
into with your mother
no unfortunately not yeah which is why
you don't do partnerships and why you
don't do partnerships with family
amen and you don't do them unless
they're all in writing and even then
when they're in writing sometimes they
blow up on you
so yeah how old are you and
i'm 24 so i bought it when i was 20.
yeah so it wasn't one right
so um the uh yeah this was unwise
obviously you're realizing that now but
now so
so the trick is this if the house has
the duplex sold
yes sir it is false i actually have i
mean we have the check
sitting um with us has been both of our
names
and oh good i haven't had to sit down
and have this conversation with her
because i'm really not sure
you know where to push it or where to i
guess
push over the i mean i obviously don't
want to ruin my relationship
with her yeah but if you have to buy a
relationship with someone that's called
prostitution right right okay
this is that's not a real relationship
when you have to pay for it
right you have to pay someone to be your
friend they're not a real friend right
you need to pay someone to be your mom
they're not a real mom
i'm so sorry this is so hard for you at
24 years old
to face your domineering mother who is a
test pilot for a broom factory
this is so hard and i'm trying to i mean
i'm trying to start my life my family
are
trying to buy property and stuff and in
your mind
in your mind is very very clear that
there was a 50 50 promise
made yes sir and we and when we improved
it we
split everything 50 50 um as far as the
outside stuff
paid the taxes you paid the bills
everything 50 50.
so i paid half of the mortgage every
month everything
that's absolute asinine yeah that she
wants more than 50
what is your mom why would she why she
needs the money for something doesn't
she
um yes so she you know has bought
um a new truck and we have horses and
she went out and bought a new horse
trailer and stuff like that and so she
needs to pay that stuff off in order
for herself to go buy a home yeah who's
got
we have horses well she
they're her she has horses she trains
horses okay you don't have partnership
in horses with her too
no sir okay okay so
listen kayla this is gonna this is gonna
be a very painful thing for you
and it's not your fault okay
because you're not going to win there's
not going to be a win
in this scenario win number wait way to
lose number one
is to do the wrong thing morally and let
her get away with this bullying tactic
and giving her more than half that's way
number one out of this that's not good
that sucks
way number two is you say mom we paid 50
of the bills this has been 50 i'm sorry
you thought it was something else
it's not we are going to the bank
together we are going to cash
this check at the bank and i'm going to
put 50 of it into my account you're
going to put 50
of it into your account if that makes
you angry i am
so sorry i'm not here to make you angry
but we are going to do the deal that we
originally promised
and guess what she's going to be angry
very
and that's going to suck yeah because
that's just your mom
yeah and this is not the first time
she's pulled crap like this either is it
no she likes to hold a lot of stuff over
my head i mean one of the things that
she
merely told me when we talked about this
a little bit was
that she's taking care of me for the you
know 18 years no that's her freaking
job she's a mother i changed your
diapers oh you
travel agent for a guilt trip
unbelievable
yeah yeah this this let me i know why
she's divorced
uh oh goodness gracious oh my goodness
calm down dave calm down
nah man this because this is just wrong
i mean this is a 24 year old daughter
come on lady have a have an ounce of
morality yeah have an ounce of ethics in
your life
instead of pulling this crap so yeah you
need to
kayla you've got you've got to be very
kind and calm and very strong
and just say mom i know you're not gonna
like this and i'm sorry
it's not it's not really i can't affect
what you decide
all i can decide all i can tell you is
is that we've decided 15
50 i've always paid 50 percent of the
bills we've always known it's 50
and that's not going to change if you
want to cash this check we're going to
do it together
at the bank and 50 is going to go in my
account and 50 is going to go in your
account
it's not negotiable mom yeah not and can
be prepared for her to be angry and do
her guilt trip
dance and all the stuff that she does
yeah is there any
do you have any siblings or someone who
like in a family that can
go and have that conversation with you
that can really have both y'alls back
saying this is the right thing
to do um no
i'm the only i'm an only child but my
dad um she just got the word from her
second marriage so my dad i mean we're
all one
level firm yeah but that
her ex is not going to make her do the
right thing
you know yeah i don't i don't know this
is my first question i don't i mean i
understand she gives me the trip of like
she has to restart and
my boyfriend and i have no no i don't
really it's almost like
i don't really care about her problems
yeah i don't care about her
about somebody else and don't don't
allow your mom's problems to become your
problems
exactly you know those are your mom's
problems for a reason
as long as you can say this is an unfair
situation for you to be in at 24 years
old i'm so sorry you're there
yeah i'm begging you to do what you know
in your heart is the right thing and to
do it with great strength
and with great kindness and with great
courage
and with no expectation of anything from
her
except a negative result she's not going
to be happy and you know that
but if you make her happy you're going
to regret it the rest of your life
that you caved to this woman that's a
bully
and it's it's just it's sad that your
mom is acting this way i'm so sorry for
you
but please do the right thing and make
her do what she's supposed to do i mean
it's just
it's so hard it's so unfair to have to
fight that battle when you're 24 years
old
it is dave it's just some people's
parents
you know wow